it's being called Europe's most hackable
election European leaders are worried
that the EU parliamentary vote is at
risk they say a foreign nation could
spread mistrust in the results or even
hack the election system altogether we
have European elections coming up now I
don't want to conjure up or predict
anything but we have to be ready to stop
interference in these elections so why
are they so worried
well this election is a big target first
citizens in 28 different countries are
taking part that means 28 different ways
of counting and tracking ballots must
dozens of different IT systems and vote
tallying machines and there's been no EU
wide check on any of it plus voting
takes place across four days that means
there's more time than usual
for a hacker to potentially do damage
and it's being called the most important
EU vote in decades with the direction of
the Union potentially at stake foreign
nations will be tempted to tip the
scales likely towards parties that hope
to weaken the EU we should take the
speck seriously because in the end it is
about our democracy and securing our
democracy against attackers who have a
huge interest in destabilizing and that
we're not trusting our institutions
hackers have targeted European
governments before election websites in
Bulgaria Poland Spain and other
countries have all been attacked in the
last few years
earlier this year a 20 year old German
managed to hack and release the personal
information of nearly 1,000 German
politicians and if he can do it why
couldn't Russia
well back in 2015
Russian hackers spent weeks inside the
German Parliament's computer network and
the cyber security company fire I
recently discovered Russian hacking
attempts on European election monitoring
systems but you don't even need to hack
an election to potentially affect its
result this information is also a threat
in 2016 a Russian campaign on social
media might have helped swing the u.s.
presidential election in favor of Donald
Trump some EU member states are starting
to fight back with efforts to safeguard
their votes so I think Sweden what
they've done prior to the election for
example is first to analyze where are
their vulnerabilities technical and then
also know maybe it was in the public and
they've also created measures like
informing the public proactively on what
technologies are used you know you
should be aware that there might be
actors that want to influence you via
disinformation they put out leaflets and
I think that's a really good proactive
strategy on informing every single
citizen the EU recently doubled its
budget for fighting disinformation and
set up a new system for sharing threats
in real-time between member states the
question is is that enough because in
this election if the results in just one
EU country are affected that could cast
doubt on the entire outcome
you